starting monday some students will catch
a ride to school with rtc instead of a
traditional school bus that's right the
ride on program is a new way ccsd is
working to get students to school on
time kate houston is live in our studio
to break down how it all works yes
hundreds of driver vacancies and
chronically late buses have created
major issues for many families this
school year the new program will impact
around 4 000 students and redirect
resources to other bus routes
the ride on program will take over 47
bus routes at 15 high schools schools
that were selected have rtc bus stops
close by and buses running every 15 to
30 minutes student eligibility is based
on the frequency of nearby bus routes
the proximity to a student's home and in
areas where ccsd transportation is not
available
student michael plummer says this gives
him more flexibility i've missed the bus
multiple times i mean it happens you
know you're running late one day but
like they said the buses are five to ten
minutes every time so even if i missed
my first bus i'm still here with 10
minutes to spare to still get to class
all rtc buses are equipped with 12
cameras that have a live look feature
for law enforcement some have security
guards on them rtc buses are also
designated safe places for minors
there are three informational google
meet sessions for families this week
there is one tonight starting at 5 pm
and for information on how to access
those meetings you can head to our
website 8newsnow.com